Hello. My name is
Atanas Kyriakov,
and I'll provide
you an overview
on how RDF overtook
the advantages
of property graphs
in the recent
years and what are the key
benefits that it still has and
bears for knowledge
graph applications.
To continue with
a quick introduction,
I'm the founder of OntoText.
We, Samantha back in year two
thousand as semantic web and
semantic technology pioneer.
Now we are best known
as the developer
of GraphDB, one of the most
popular database engines.
We are an enterprise knowledge
graph top leader,
and we enjoy being the center
of an ecosystem of more than
twenty partners
all the way from
portfolio partners
which complement
our technology to,
consulting and and
delivery partners.
We are profitable in growing.
We have, among our
customers, yeah,
the leaders in many fields,
like in financial
services, in in,
yeah, media and publishing,
in government, aerospace,
health care life sciences,
or infrastructure management
like Johnson and Schneider
Schneider Electric.
We are also involved in all
sorts of
standardization bodies
that have something to do with
it because we we care about
the future of this of this
technology and,
this this trend.
To give you, yeah, a graphy,
introduction to
what we are doing,
We are here to
connect the dots
of your enterprise knowledge.
We do this by, yeah,
basically combining
and fusing and and,
making your
proprietary information
smarter. Our special
way to do this,
special sauce,
a special ingredient
is that we use deep domain
knowledge to enrich
your proprietary,
information. And,
the way in which we do it is
that we we put
together, we create,
we craft, we help you craft,
rich knowledge
gaps that enable
unified data views
and this way,
more more more deeper and more
more more fruitful analytics.
The way in which
we create these
knowledge graphs is by, yeah,
linking and,
linking data across
different sources,
reconcile reconciling data,
converting strings to things,
the usual things to to to end
up with the with the body of
body of knowledge that is easy
to query and to
explore and and
and to deal with.
Well, this requires
a fair amount
of text analysis,
data analysis,
machine learnings,
all the fancy things.
And that's what more or less
everyone does. Again,
our special associates that we
we we've been
maturing for twenty
years how we can use,
almost exhaustive
domain knowledge,
big bonus of
to to to provide context,
and to to to help us
better interpret,
better recognize,
better better
classify things.
And that's that's
from the bigger
picture, the way
in which domain
knowledge, help.
Get connecting
to those of your
enterprise knowledge
and that's
first very
important ingredient
of talking about
knowledge graphs
at all. We store this
knowledge graphs.
We manage this
knowledge graphs
with our semantic database and
search engine, Graph DB.
And what's still
missing on this
picture is why we do this.
Well, we want to
give you better
insights, and
reach results for
for for results as much as
possible in less time.
That's what Graph
DB is designed
to do altogether.
On the bigger picture,
a knowledge draft management
platform should cover a bigger
set of capabilities
from yeah,
building, build build building
these big data
data artifacts,
storing index in operations,
accessibility, federation
exploration analytics.
For each of those
there, yeah,
more specific
capabilities that
should be there.
We develop a lot of these,
the orange boxes
ourselves and,
we we we we made
decision to to
use our partner
ecosystem tools
from our partners for other
capabilities. Right?
Like, some editors,
some toll generators,
data catalogs,
chatbots. So that's our way of
working in this field
because we can't,
cover it all,
at at at matching our our our
criteria for metro software.
We are, the leader
of the RDF space.
You you know, the like,
the graph database field and
the graph technology
field has,
like, property graphs chapter
and the RDF chapter.
We're in the RDF chapter.
And from this position I want
to to tell you what are,
what were
the historic advantages
of property gas
and and and how,
RDF address this.
So, the easiest argument for
someone to make,
on on on the property
graph side was,
well, in in in in
and everything
on top of it, you can attach,
properties to to edges and say
things about the edges
in the graph.
While in RDF, you can only do
so for for the notes.
And then the second big big
argument was, well,
in thinking of everything is
designed and
thought of, yeah,
providing efficient
graph traversal.
And historically,
this wasn't the case
in in RDF.
But over the last
three years,
yeah, RDF, yeah,
addressed this in a very,
very comprehensive manner.
The first thing
was, RDF star.
That's specific specification
for attached
metadata to the edge
edges of the graph
that started
two thousand fourteen,
and now there are plenty of
implementations
across different
vendors. The second
topic is, yeah,
the SPARCO extensions which
allow for graph traversal path
search and generally speaking
exploration of multiple
relationships in graphs.
So I'll continue
this presentation
with a bit more flash and
technical detail
on the how RDF
star is implemented
and how RDF
engines implement
the graph reversal.
And then, I'll give
you my view on,
yeah, what's
the added value of
knowledge graphs
and finally how
RDF enables this
this added value.
To start with, yeah,
here are the example.
If you want to encode
the information
that Abraham Lincoln was,
president of
the United States,
that's a very easy
way to to do it.
You have two nodes and,
one relationship,
one edge labeled
with president
of you can have
a slightly more
advanced version having labels
or names for the two nodes.
But the reality
check says, well,
actually, you you you have to
be able to do much
more than this.
So, you need to to provide
contextual temporal
information,
as well as provenance metadata
so that you have all the all
the important
information about
this fact, this edge.
Historically, in RDF,
there was no easy
way to attach
this information to an edge in
the graph. But yeah.
Now now it now you can see how
it works in RTS star.
So, you can have
the statement,
Abraham Lincoln,
position held president
of the United
States. And through
this entire
statement, you
can make another
statement saying,
well, this thing,
this fact,
this statement has
start starting
date whatever whatever,
literal that is
the starting date.
So you can make
statements about
statements. If you
want to look at this,
at the at the diagram,
think of having
an edge and then
being able to
make another edge
that starts from
the first one,
and making statement
about it.
That's much more
expressive than
the key value
pairs that you can
do in property graphs.
That's the most
consensual part of,
what what is coming for some
optimization in RDF
one point two.
Before before RDF star,
there were other ways to do
the same thing like standard
reconciliation in RDF or any
relationships or
singleton property,
singleton name graphs,
but those were
not very handy.
So RDF star made,
attach metadata to the notes
really simple.
And we also made
sure that the graph
implementation makes it makes
it efficient so we
have efficiency gain.
We we took
a a Wikidata fragment
that if you encode
it with the standard
verification it takes almost
four hundred million
statements.
It takes a bit
less than an hour
to load it and so on.
And then if you
encode the same
data in rdf star,
it is almost twice smaller,
less statements
and and it takes
much less time to load and it
takes much less time
on your hard drive.
So we also have, this,
RDF star support now for for
several for kind of
couple of years.
And, we have some
of our partners
already using it.
To give you the use case,
Synaptica is
the developer Graphite.
That's one of the leading
vocabulary management,
taxonomy management tools.
They use Graph DB to store,
all these taxonomies
and vocabulary
seen as cost data,
but historically
they had problem
of how how they manage their
access control lists.
And without RDFStar expressing
which users can control if you
have access to,
what access to
which properties
in which schema for
what project was,
like, what you
see at the top.
It was encoded with
five different
statements. And now
with RDF star,
it is much simple.
There are no auxiliary notes,
and you can you you need only
three statements
to encode this
information. So it's it's
obviously much simpler.
We also took care to to,
we made our homework to see,
how the other engines handle
different corner cases like,
statements, valid statements,
valid statements,
nested nested nested
embedded triples,
or how how they deal
with the situation.
Imagine you delete the triple
from from your repository,
and you want to
maintain information
about who and when
deleted this one.
So the statement
is not there,
but you should be able to keep
metadata about
it and this kind
of thing. So we
we took care to
others then well.
So by now you should
be convinced that,
yeah, edges, edges
and properties
are covered very,
very well in the RDS space.
So let's move on to the graph
traversal and how
it is implemented.
It it is
a computationally very
complex problem.
It comes in different
flavors like,
checking whether
there is a path
between two nodes or finding
the shortest path
or finding all
paths or the neighboring nodes
and stuff like this.
And what they
have in common is
that they're
computation like,
heavy problems.
Doesn't matter whether you do
a deep first search or breadth
first search, it
it is complex.
And complexity
goes exponentially
with the length of the of of
the path that you're
searching for.
So still there
there are a number
of good reasons
to to find a way
to implement it because it's
very useful for, yeah,
navigation or for knowledge
graph analysis, supply
chain management,
and so on and so forth.
There are plenty
of use cases.
So, historically, yeah,
SPARCO was able to
almost do this,
but in Sparkle one one,
you can do property pass to
discover whether
there is a path,
but you cannot get
the intermediate
notes. And it's very hard also
to to to implement in in in
spark in plain spark one one
shortest path.
There are workarounds,
but none of them is something
you are going to like,
they're also slow.
So to address this,
all the all the vendors
of the databases
did, yeah,
some extensions of sparkle to
address this. That's how our
extension looks like.
So you you you you
have a service
clause in in in
in sparkle that
where you you
tell I want to do
all paths search,
and you provide source and
destination if you want to or
just the source.
And then you can
specify the maximum
path optionally, and
so on and so forth.
You can also specify
that the the
pattern that that you want to
to to trace so
that that you can
specify specific conditions,
patterns in
the graph that need
need to be to to be there for
each step of this path.
You can also do
shortest path and,
you can do bidirectional
search also.
So we covered all all flavors
of this task. Again,
we did our excess our homework
to see how others do the same
thing and explore cases.
And, yeah,
you see that our competitors
have different advantages and
disadvantages in this field.
But what's most important for
us is that we try to keep keep
compliance so not to not to
implement it by some hacks in
the sparkle process.
So, this table wasn't oh,
yeah. In a way,
we are checking the boxes,
seeing whether whether we can
do this and that.
What really matters for us is
also whether we do it well,
whether we do it in
efficient manner.
And that's where, yeah,
benchmarks help to to see what
what is the actual complexity
with specific hardware,
with specific
volumes of data,
what are the choke points,
what are the inefficiencies,
and address those.
We use the link data,
benchmarking councils,
social network benchmark for
this purpose.
LDPC is a TPC like
industry body
of the graph the graph
database vendors,
on space, Neo four j, CVI.
We're among
the the the the founders.
And then now you have
all the all the,
yeah, major graph
database vendors
in there. A few words about
the specific benchmark.
SMB is the most comprehensive
graph on it is benchmark.
It simulates the kind
of questions
that you would
ask for the data
behind the social
network platform.
And there were,
many many person
years invested
in making good
data generators.
So this graph is
both realistic
and and challenging and covers
all the distributions and
connectivity patterns in an in
an interesting fashion so that
you can really
challenge the engines
and and compare them.
To give you feeling
of the data model,
so you have relations between
between people like,
knows relationship.
You have attributes for people
like addresses, these
cities and so on.
You have relationships also
between people
and companies or
university and
stuff like that.
There are different
sets of queries,
and, yeah,
the interactive queries,
you have, like, one
of them saying,
well, let let's get all all
the people that you can get
within three steps following
the nose relationship
from a given
person or find
the shortest path
between two persons.
So this this is
what these queries
are like.
And Graph DB is the first RDF
engine to pass
the to pass this
benchmark. We do
this in a stepwise
manner so we we
are essentially
push pushing the boundaries of
what we can get
out of workstation
or mid range
server with yeah,
the thirty thirty two to sixty
four gigabytes of RAM.
So far, we got wonderful
results with,
at scale factor ten,
which is half a billion edges
graph with social
network graph
with half a billion edges.
And we're working now to to to
to to the next scales and get
it to the five billion edges.
So we benchmark
Graph DB against
the one of the most
popular top
three graphs engines,
and we we score
very, very well.
We we get better results on
the interactive queries.
And I gotta admit
we we are a bit
slower on loading the data and
and and updates.
One way in which we can take
benefit of what RDF engines do
well is to use
inference and we
extensively use inference for
this purpose.
So for instance when you have
to to follow a a a a path that
involves two types
of relationships,
knows and has
person, you know,
on each step, in
the chain like,
right here.
We use inference to to do some
sort of shortcuts,
these direct nodes,
relationships which
are shortcuts
of the relationships
that we're
trying to follow,
and this allowed
us to simplify
the query.
And this way, yeah,
we made a query
that takes half
a minute thirty
times faster and
gets sub sub sub
second responses.
So materialization
using inference
could be could be
very, very useful,
for some of these tasks.
So we we we get also the craft
reversal and then the finding
part in the craft to recover.
So, let's see what
what the benefits,
what what are knowledge graphs
graphs all about and how they
differ from other
ways of doing
similar things.
So a quick quiz,
let's think a little
bit on what are,
what is in common
between these,
these IT problems,
these information management
problems that that
that I list for you.
So think of a a a very,
very big,
retail bank that wants to
consolidate
information because
it's IT systems
to do root cause
analysis whenever
there is a problem
like an ATM not functioning.
Or a market market
intelligence agency,
that is that is the,
provides reference
price for oil
and gas. They need to to have
a really rich set of signals
about everything that may have
something that may may impact
the price of oil
and gas on some
markets sometime.
Or big investment
advisory that
wants to have the best
m and a intelligence
database on earth with
all the companies
and all the transactions
and all
the sections that you can do
analysis by industries and
technologies and so
on and so forth.
Or the fourth case here,
building management
system, yeah,
consolidating the information
about all all sorts of systems
in a big building,
like, the elevators,
heating, ventilation,
electricity,
access control, and,
everything like that.
Then finally,
I think of a pharma
company that
receives a compliance,
a regular inquiry
from FDA about
side effects of drugs,
and they gotta find relevant
information in,
within really
thousands of long
reports from clinical
trials of drugs.
What these problems have in
common is that we have proven
through the years
that the knowledge
graphs can help for each and
every of those problems.
And what then what makes them
specific and and
complex is that,
well, you need a unified view
across diverse information to
be able to address them.
So you need to combine several
databases developed with us
without in in
different departments
of finding the same
organization,
and to also use information
extract information from,
documents and
unstructured content.
And quite often
to to to to get
this right, you need to use
external knowledge,
global domain knowledge in
combination with
the proprietary data.
And, this is this is very,
very specific and
very important for,
domains where you have to deal
and tasks where
we have you have
to deal with hundreds
of thousands
of concepts and entities.
Or even if there
are not that many,
situations where you have very
complex interconnections
and lots of,
relationships, not
just the taxonomy,
but more complex relationships
between between,
concepts and entities
within the domain,
as well as situations where,
the the semantics of
the relationships
really matter to properly
interpret the data.
So, yeah, to to to
to wrap it up,
what what knowledge graphs do
in these cases is
that they they
they provide the business with
competitive insights through
better intelligence.
And better
intelligence means,
deeper understanding
of the data
based on a deeper knowledge,
copy of signals that you can
derive from diverse data,
and also instantaneous updates
that that that
that come if you
have data fabric or another
another data
integration platform
that gives you flexibility and
and sustainable updates.
This is all these all these
capabilities is what makes
knowledge graph,
helps knowledge
knowledge graphs,
disrupt several
existing information
management fields like content
management, data management,
knowledge management,
and nowadays more
and more from
the business
process management
and automation industry and
infrastructure, and and and
manufacturing. So you you see
that in the terminal nodes of
this map of graph,
you have plenty of plenty of
different applications,
that that we have
seen knowledge
gaps being being
successful so far.
So, the added value,
to to again wrap it up is that
knowledge graphs can,
serve as a helper
across different
systems, data management,
content management,
and all sorts of
metadata across them.
And what's more important,
we we we we layer
semantic metadata,
on on top of all
these all these
knowledge to make it
easy easier to use.
So on the technical side,
what what it means
in practice,
is point one linking
data together
so that you can interpret them
better because a conceptual
network of thousands
of concepts can,
provide much more
information,
and computers can
take much more
meaning out of it as
comparative tables,
having the same
data in in tables.
Then the second
thing would be is,
to overlay semantic
metadata to
avoid
unambiguous interpretation
because when you get data from
different sources,
it is very likely
that in a different
context,
the information can be
misinterpreted. Having proper
the specification
of the meaning
of the different
data pieces is
very important.
Knowing what kind
of price is this,
whether it's with
or without VAT,
whether it's before or after
sales commission,
all these small things is what
you need to describe in a very
good manner so
that you can get
a unique useful
useful unified use.
And the worst
thing here is that
you you you,
if you have
a a stable semantic
data model, and and
the reference data,
that's that's the way to to
basically have
continuous updates
of your data and to be able to
reuse data prepared for other
analytic purposes beforehand.
So finally,
what is that RDF
does better to
to to cover all
these capabilities
that are necessary for for
knowledge graphs,
as compared to any other data
management paradigm.
So explicit
semantics that that
allows you to
align the meaning
of the different,
modeling consumptions across
different IT
systems as well as
you can use semantics for to
validate data on a semantic
level to check
consistencies and
this way maintain the quality
of this combined
combined data set.
There are plenty
of features in
RDF that foster
interoperability.
So that's federation protocols
and remote access
protocols as well as,
different flavors of syntax,
that that that
really help easy
easy exchange of data.
Global identifiers,
which make sure that when you
put two date two two piece of
data from different
sources together,
the the the things
that must be
linked there will
will click and
link automatically,
and there will be
no no identifier
clashes. And, finally,
there is there there there are
thousands of
datasets available
as RDF as linked data.
Life science is good example,
but now we we see
more and more
of this also in the,
industry and
the infrastructure.
You may not know, but,
now you can get the entire
information about
the electricity
grids and network,
in in Europe,
in RDF and do quite a lot of
interesting things with it.
Finally, it's
about standards,
standards about everything,
standard serialization
syntax formats,
schema languages,
query languages,
update languages,
and everything
on top of this.
Using standards is we have can
can come at a cost
at the beginning,
but, this is what what what
makes your data management
enterprise data
management setup
future proof. And
also standards
is what what what
gives you great,
yeah, much lower
levels of vendor
lock in.
And what is that
property graphs
lack to serve such knowledge
graph platforms? Well,
it's all of this.
So there is no
formal semantics,
there is very
little to help you
in terms of interoperability.
And, yeah, standardization,
they just started.
So probably in five
or ten years,
it will be there.
So RDF engines, yeah,
the best platform to implement
knowledge graphs,
they check all
the boxes and now
also traversal and analytics,
along with, yeah,
all the all the enterprise
requirements.
And, yeah, I have to be fair
that there's still
case in which
property graphs are better.
So if you want to do some very
specific programming
Gremlin to
explore graph, yeah,
that's the way to do it.
Or if you if you want to do
really really heavy analytics
with petabytes of data,
then you you you take
a rack full of,
yeah, servers
with terabytes of
RAM And again, property graphs
are likely to serve
you a bit better.
For everything else,
RDF is what you
need to get your
graph infrastructure
right. Thank you.